Let’s solve some aromaticity problems. We
have a two-part question here—we need to
classify the compounds as aromatic, non-aromatic,
or antiaromatic, and draw the lone pairs on
heteroatoms and determine if they participate
in the π system or are orthogonal to it.
A heteroatom is a non-carbon atom, and orthogonal
means the lone pair is perpendicular to the
π system; this is important because it cannot
participate in the π system when orthogonal.
Maybe pause the video here and try to classify
these compounds on your own; when you resume,
we can solve the problems together.
As a refresher, let’s review the criteria
for aromaticity. The compound must be cyclic
and planar. In our examples, we have relatively
small rings containing double bonds, so planarity
is probably not a major concern in our problems,
but it can be with larger rings. The compound
must also be conjugated; the continuous π
system within the ring can be made up of sp2
hybridized atoms and lone pairs. Finally,
the number of electrons in the π system must
satisfy Huckel’s rule, having 4n+2 π electrons.
I’ll abbreviate electrons “e minus.”
Now, if we replace “n” with zero or small,
positive integers, we find that our π system
must have a specific number of electrons to
be aromatic. We may also need to identify
antiaromatic compounds, which are cyclic,
planar compounds that have a continuous π
system containing 4n π electrons. Antiaromatic
compounds are very unstable.
In problem (a), we have alternating single
and double bonds, and we can see this pattern
continues across two rings. We can draw a
resonance form to show electron delocalization
over the bicyclic compound. Remember each
of our representations is an average of the
actual structure, although it looks like this
bond has moved here, and this bond has moved
to the other ring. Let’s count π electrons.
Each double bond is made up of two electrons,
so we have 2, 4, 6, 8 π electrons in this
system, which makes it antiaromatic.
Moving from a hydrocarbon example to a heterocycle
with nitrogen atoms in the ring, we have a
bit of a different situation. Each nitrogen
has a lone pair, so we need to figure out
whether or not they can participate in the
π system.
It’s helpful to look at a model for this
one. We can see the blue double bonds and
green single bonds, which is a reasonable
representation for the π system in this static
model, even though in reality delocalization
makes each bond more like a one-and-a-half
bond. Notice the geometry at nitrogen. Since
it is sp2 hybridized, the lone pair must fit
into this hole, which sticks out at a 120
º angle to the other bonds. The π system
is delocalized above and below the ring, so
the lone pairs on an sp2-hybridized nitrogen
are orthogonal to the aromatic π-system.
So, this compound, called pyrazine, has three
double bonds in the ring, making the compound
aromatic and it also has two orthogonal lone
pairs.
Problem (c) has a positively charged nitrogen.
It has shared its lone pair to bond with oxygen,
forming an N-oxide functional group. It has
4 bonds, which gives it tetrahedral geometry
and makes it sp3 hybridized. The sp3 nitrogen
atom disrupts conjugation in the ring, and
this compound is non-aromatic.
Problem (d) is an interesting example. Each
oxygen has two lone pairs, so each atom in
the ring has either a lone pair, or is sp2
hybridized. However, this compound is non-aromatic
as drawn. Let’s examine why. We can show
a resonance form by pushing electrons through
the entire conjugated system, putting a negative
charge on the oxygen outside of the ring and
using one of the lone pairs of the ring oxygen.
We had to push electrons in a path that led
outside of the ring to show this resonance
form, thus the conjugated system is not continuous
within the ring, so the compound on the left
is non-aromatic. Now, the form on the right
does indeed have aromatic character, but because
of the charge separation, it contributes less
to the overall structure. Also, our problem
asked if the compound was aromatic as drawn.
There is a second way to push electrons in
this system, but it also relies on conjugation
with the exocyclic double bond.
In compound (e), we again have a sp2 nitrogen
with an orthogonal lone pair.
If we look at the model of this compound,
it is so strained the double bonds are bending,
but it certainly is planar.
Since two double bonds make up the pi system,
this is an antiaromatic compound.
This compound with the positively charged
sulfur atom has three double bonds within
the ring. So, what about the lone pairs on
sulfur?
Sulfur is in the same group as oxygen on the
periodic table, so only considering the valence
sp hybrid orbital, we can draw a lone pair
on sulfur that does not participate in the
π system. This compound has 6 π electrons
and is aromatic.
In our final example, we should recognize
immediately that the nitrogen lone pairs are
orthogonal to the π system. We can draw two
lone pairs on sulfur, one of which participates
in the π system. Geometrically, the second
lone pair cannot participate, so it is outside
of the π system, though maybe not exactly
perpendicular to it. Given the two double
bonds in the ring and the lone pair on sulfur,
compound (g) is aromatic.